my name is areum young jr. but and I was
born here in Christian County in the
Herndon community on the seventh day of
January 1919 when my dad first got the
idea of no-tillage and as I said that
was in southern Illinois George McKibben
had had the test plot that he saw he
came home and said I think I can do that
so he found an old two row mule drawn
planter that was sitting in the fence
row rusting he got the idea of how he
could adapt that for no-tillage he took
it to a local shop because my
grandfather my uncle my dad at that time
didn't even have a welder on the farm so
he took it down to the place where
everybody went to get their welding done
Rob's shop run by Rob Thomas and he
explained to him what he wanted to have
done he made it adapted to go underneath
a 140 Farmall tractor and Rob Thomas did
the welding put it together we mounted
it I say we my dad mounted it on the 140
and took the chance of his life to go
out and actually plant a crop that had
not been tilled in any way previous to
that planting and that was the way it
began what does Katherine think of no
tillage on the farm do you have an
opinion on no tillage on the yeah no
tillage is the way we plant crops with
the planter instead of plowing up the
ground we burn it back with chemical and
then we put the seed right in the ground
without doing anything so it's there is
no tillage involved that's why it's
called no tillage it is an honor to be
part of the lineage just the the
heritage I guess that's an overused word
I think when you talk about generational
farms but it really is a family
tradition one of experimentation and
innovation in 1962 their total corn crop
was 92 acres
he and my uncle and my grandfather at
that time farm together right now my son
Alexander and I and the other family
members and land owners plant about 2300
acres of corn 2300 acres of wheat and
2300 acres of soybeans so we have in the
neighborhood of 4600 acres of land from
which we get those double crop soybeans
planted behind tweet so I guess that
would be around 69 hundred acres so
that's quite a change quite a quite a
enlargement but you know that's kind of
the way things are the farmers have to
get bigger in order to support their
families it's a very tight economic
situation has been up and down for years
and that's some of the reason why we've
had expansion our spray program has
changed quite a bit over time believe it
or not though one of the standard
chemicals that my dad used in 1962
atrazine is still with us and it has
still been a remarkably good product and
very little resistance at least
effective resistance has developed other
things have come along that attack
different modes of action and I must say
that the the chemical companies have
done more to advance no tillage and
therefore the saving of topsoil than
just about any other part of the
agribusiness community without
herbicides without those chemicals no
tillage would not work and if no tillage
doesn't work then you have the topsoil
which is going to end up in Kentucky
going all the way to New Orleans and
forming sediment that increases the
Delta there's always a trade-off in
anything that we do you can only be one
place at a time you can only go to one
church at a time
you can only be the member of one family
at a time and as far as agriculture goes
you can only do one method at a time on
any given location whether it's an acre
or a field and that's why I say that
it's very
or that we understand that if we go back
to the time when we till the soil
whether you want to do it from organic
production or any other method if you're
going to tell the soil you're gonna lose
the soil it was proven to be the case
before there was no tillage and I think
it's still the case you cannot tell the
soil without losing the soil no tillage
it's the best thing I know of at the
moment it may not be perfect but it's
the best thing I know of at the moment
to keep the soil where it belongs and
that's right here on the family farm
well it's a great act of conservation
the conservation of the soil the
preservation of our ecosystem you know
the the breeding of wildlife that comes
from no-till farming it's really neat to
be part of that tradition no tillage was
started as a way to preserve the soil
and to conserve the soil to keep it
where it where it needs to be which is
on the home farm we've seen a lot of
improvements in that the sheet erosion
is pretty much controlled now even
though there is some problem with gully
erosion no matter no matter what kind of
practices you use you can have a
permanent pasture and you still have
some gully erosion but the land itself
is improved as the soil organic matter
is improved some people nowadays call it
carbon sequestration I call it soil
organic matter because that's what
really allows us to maintain fertility
and tilth and productivity in a soil
when I was a child and my dad was first
starting this back in the early 1960s an
average soil test would be about one and
a half percent organic matter we
consistently have three percent or three
and a half percent organic matter now in
our soil tests simply because the land
has been allowed to accumulate the
carbon which is in effect organic matter
and that in turn keeps it from washing
away as easily it makes it more
productive it keeps the nutrients where
they belong
and it doesn't allow things to wash down
the river and and cause trouble and
pollution the old saying used to be
no-till no crop
and that was people who cast aspersions
at it to say well if you want to try
that you can but you're not going to get
anything out of it well he knew it would
work because he had tried it in fact
when dr. Shirley Phillips came down for
the very first time to talk to my dad by
his own statement dr. Phillips said he
came down to prove that it wouldn't work
and he got down here and he checked and
he found out that it did work and my
goodness we better get on board with
that you know I'd like to sit guaranty
that I could see all this opportunity
developing and so forth but I was about
as reluctant about it no-tillage about
as much as anyone at the point in time
in fact I guess I really started out to
prove that it wouldn't work and much to
my surprise it did so he and my dad
became fast friends there were still a
lot of skepticism and there still is
there still farmers who don't plant
their crops no tillage I can't explain
why you'd have to ask them but for us
it's been good it has proven itself to
be a highly productive highly efficient
way of farming and I'm thankful that he
did what he did
Shirley and I early on we had worked
very closely together in developing no
tillage techniques and one day he was
coming down and I met him at a country
store to get a sandwich and we got to
talking and at that time we thought we
had amassed enough information that we
could write a book and so we sought of
dared each other why don't we why don't
we put what we know and what we have
been able to learn
research people in other states together
and write a book on no-tillage farming
we decided to do it I spoke to a group a
few years ago the local Daughters of the
American Revolution about no-till
farming and one of the articles I
referenced was a conservation study
Wildlife numbers and things that you
wouldn't associate with row crop farming
they found that the numbers of not
endangered species but species of
animals that were thinning were
bolstered in a no-till system you have
greater greater life in the soil which
attracts birds and things that would be
attracted to the worms and the bugs that
come into a no-till system and then you
have predators that prey on the birds
and you just have an increase in that
ecosystem it is really amazing how such
a small thing as not working your soil
and letting it wash away impacts the
whole environment and so to be part of
that not just to have a grandfather that
helped pioneer it but to take part in it
to use it on the farm it's really an
awesome opportunity you know we've been
doing cover crops for 50 years our cover
crop is called wheat we plant wheat
immediately following corn and then we
plant beans immediately following the
wheat so the only time that our ground
is not covered specifically with a cover
crop might be in between the November
harvest of the double crop soybeans and
the April planting of the next year's
corn crop so we've done cover crops in
Western Kentucky Wow for decades I would
love to be able to plant cover crops
after the soybeans and have something
that I can actually harvest and sell
before I plant corn the following spring
I have yet to find that and I have asked
a lot of people about what I can what I
can find to sell they say well you're
you're missing the point John you need
to just plant it for the benefit of the
cover crop itself and to some extent
that's true
the land is always better when it has
something green that's growing on it
it's just like every bit of Agriculture
there's always more to know we don't
know a lot
in fact I'll reference one of my
favorite quotations from one of my
favorite inventors Thomas Edison he said
and I think it's still true we don't
know one millionth of 1% of anything
there's so much yet to discover and so
much yet to develop we just think we
know it all but we really don't God
knows it all and we don't know one
millionth of one percent of anything
unfortunately we've had a rainy weekend
we cannot plant corn we would love to be
in the corn fields here but instead
we're hulling last season's corn we've
got our grain system here we're loading
out a truck it's going to go to our
local farmer owned cooperative and
they'll sell it for ethanol for carbon
dioxide and for animal feed and there
are other sub markets some of it goes to
distilleries some of it goes to hog
houses chicken houses dog food but they
do an excellent job of marketing the
owners the farmers commodities that we
deliver you know my dad graduated from
the University of Kentucky with a
master's degree and I did my
undergraduate work at the University of
Kentucky and we've had a lot of
communication through the years with the
staff at Princeton Experiment Station
dr. Lloyd Murdoch is a good example
Lloyd Murdoch is a man who I would say
if he says something you can take it to
the bank and he has specifically done
work with cover crops and I think most
recently on rye grass on a corn soybean
rotation and how it has helped alleviate
the pain the natural occurring pan in
some of our Western Kentucky poorly
drained soils I will I would go to them
in a heartbeat if I have a problem
either with an unknown disease or a soil
fertility question and I'm looking
forward to the expanded Experiment
Station
at Princeton and I hope they'll prove to
be just as efficient and professional as
the ones that I've known in the past
[Music]
you